Ethan Suplee made a name
for himself as the lovable,
beefy Louie in "Remember the Titans,"
but you wouldn't recognize him today…
could a come to Jesus moment with a man
who once played Jesus be the reason why?
If you've been following Ethan Suplee's career,
you know much of it has been spent playing,
in his own words, "roles for fat kids." After
decades of being the butt of fat kid jokes
and searching for a weight-loss program that
worked, Suplee finally found one that stuck,
and helped him get down from his
heaviest weight of over 530 pounds.
"I'm now 260. In between there, there
was weight loss and weight gain."
The actor has been showcasing his new physique on
Instagram of late, and fans who've been following
him for decades are finding it hard to believe
the buff guy in the pictures is actually him.
So impressive is Suplee's transformation,
the actor was showcased in Men's Health in
a January 2020 interview. He spoke candidly
about his struggles to not just lose weight,
but keep it off amid a busy work
schedule that didn't allow for
much time in the gym, saying -
"I wasn't factoring in how I was
going to maintain my weight at work when I was
working like, 14 hours a day, five days a week."
Counterintuitively, it was Suplee's
demanding work-life that actually
placed him in a position to make
healthy changes in the first place.
While the beloved character actor is
famous for his scene-stealing turns in
dramatic films like "American History X"
and zany sitcoms like former must-see TV
staple "My Name Is Earl," it's one
of Suplee's most under-appreciated
performances that he actually credits
with introducing him to the gym.
It seems his casting on Hulu's" Chance,"
which required some weight training,
combined with a revelatory TED
Talk about the science of food
helped Suplee find the right
mix. He told Men's Health -
"The most important thing I would want
anyone to take away is that for me,
the biggest change was understanding how food
works. And the more I feel that I understand,
scientifically, the more power I have over it."
On "Chance," Suplee played fan-favorite
Darius "D" Pringle opposite Hugh Laurie's
titular neuropsychiatrist. On the show, which
only ran for two woefully under-watched seasons
between 2016 and 2017, Suplee debuted a notably
more toned physique than the one he made famous
in earlier appearances — though nothing
on par with the bod he's rocking today.
When "Chance" was canceled, Suplee must have
made a commitment to stick to his routine.
At the same time Ethan Suplee was showing
off his reformed figure on "Chance," he was
also appearing in a recurring capacity
on Netflix's hit sitcom "The Ranch,"
where he played Colt and Rooster's high
school buddy, Billy "Beer Pong" Tonkins,
who just so happens to be Officer Tonkins
now. A fan-favorite guest star, Suplee
shows up on 13 episodes across all four seasons,
reminding viewers of his genuine acting range.
"You're using your holster to hold a beer."
"Yeah. Pretty cool huh? Wait - where's my gun?"
After "Chance" was canceled, Suplee was
forced to find work elsewhere. In 2017,
he appeared as Bill Shaker on the "Twin
Peaks" revival season before playing
Tommy for six episodes in Season 3 of "Santa
Clarita Diet." From there, he played Gil on
"Good Girls" in 2020 and even voiced Bob
the Bigfoot on the animated "Vampirina."
Unfortunately, those are the last recurring
television roles Suplee has had in the past few
years. Sure, he's slated to appear in the Indian
comedy series "The Pradeeps of Pittsburgh" once
the current SAG-AFTRA strike ends, but here's
hoping he finds his way back to a hit show.
Of course, Ethan Suplee was known for his work on
the big screen long before he became a TV star,
and he's still relatively active
in Hollywood today. In 2016,
Suplee appeared in Peter Berg's "Deepwater
Horizon'' alongside Mark Wahlberg and
Kurt Russell, playing an oil rig worker
named Jason Anderson. A few years later,
he played Gilbert Coney in Edward Nortion's
period private eye flick, "Motherless Brooklyn."
His most controversial feature came out
in 2020, as Suplee was one of those who
appeared in the satirical political
thriller "The Hunt." Playing Gary,
the conspiracy theorist podcaster with a chip
on his shoulder, Suplee showed off his new look
on the big screen, though not for long. Within
the movie's first week of release, the COVID-19
pandemic closed movie theaters everywhere,
forcing the Blumhouse production underground.
Thankfully, the failure of "The Hunt" didn't
prevent Suplee from landing other roles. In 2022,
he appeared in "Dog" opposite Channing Tatum
and Damien Chazelle's Hollywood epic, "Babylon."
The following year, he had three movies come out,
"Manodrome," "Blood for Dust," and the
action crime thriller "God Is a Bullet."
Since the beginning of Ethan Suplee's career,
the actor has collaborated with some pretty big
names. After "Remember the Titans," he worked
with Denzel Washington again on "John Q." and
"Unstoppable." Following "American History
X," he reunited with Edward Norton nearly
two decades later for "Motherless Brooklyn."
Additionally, he and Ashton Kutcher have starred
opposite one another a few times, including "The
Butterfly Effect," the comedy short "A Night of
140 Tweets," and "The Ranch." But Suplee's most
frequent collaborator extends back to his roots.
In 1995, Suplee landed his first feature film, a
small indie flick directed by Kevin Smith called
"Mallrats." From then on, Suplee and Smith kept
working together, with the former appearing in
other Smith-directed productions: "Chasing
Amy," "Dogma," Clerks II," and "Clerks III."
Amazingly, these two have also collaborated
on projects Smith didn't direct. They both
appear in "Fanboys," "Drawing Flies," and
"Vulgar," the latter of which Smith executive
produced. Additionally, Smith produced
"A Better Place," which features Suplee,
and the two appeared in the same "A Night
of 140 Tweets" special Kutcher was in.
Although it's more common to see Hollywood actors
play video game characters in movie or television
adaptations, since the 2010s, it's become
increasingly popular to see actors transition
from the filmmaking world into the video game
space. In 2022, Ethan Suplee continued that trend,
playing the mysterious hunter Bobby in
the interactive horror game "The Quarry."
One part "Friday the 13th," one part
"The Thing," and all parts frightening,
"The Quarry" is a slasher game that preys
upon your fears of the unknown and stars a
pretty impressive cast. Suplee's role is
somewhat out-of-character for the actor,
but that's part of what makes his
transition to video games so special.
Beyond acting, Ethan Suplee has kept himself
fairly busy, and not just in the gym. Outside
of his fitness regimen, Suplee hosts a podcast,
"American Glutton," where he "sets out to examine
our current obesity crisis." To do this, Suplee
is candid about his own battle with weight loss
and dietary health and often brings on
experts and others with similar stories
to help set the stage and encourage people
to get healthy. He even runs a regularly
updated blog through the podcast's website,
sharing the stories of many of his listeners.
Naturally, "American Glutton" also features a
variety of celebrity guests, including those
Suplee has previously worked with. With folks
like his "Unstoppable" co-star T.J. Miller,
former "My Name is Earl" guest
star Michael Peña, Kevin Smith,
and Josh Peck, Suplee does his best to
break any stigmas attached to weight loss,
all the while encouraging those
who feel hopeless to push on.
In an interview with Michael Rosenbaum on his
"Inside of You" podcast, Suplee shares that
his producer, Kevin Connolly, wanted him
to host a politically-based podcast. But,
uninterested in sharing his political
views in fear of being canceled,
he shifted the topic entirely, and from
there, "American Glutton" was born.
"One day I woke up when he was
asking me and I was like, ' I
could fully talk about health and
fitness because I've done that.'"
Despite the personal success Ethan Suplee
found in his physical transformation and his
podcast's impact on countless others, changing his
entire look hasn't been the easiest thing for his
career. Speaking about the series "Chance,"
he told Entertainment Weekly back in 2017 -
"Initially, the casting directors
didn't want me to come in because
I'd lost a bunch of weight. Apparently
they had proposed me a bunch of times,
but the casting directors were
like, 'No, he's too thin now.'"
The actor notes that after "My Name is Earl,"
which ended in 2009, he got down to 9% body fat
by continuously riding bicycles. But because of
his dramatic weight loss, nobody recognized him
as the same person. It was then that Suplee took a
different approach, telling Entertainment Weekly -
"I'm not going to kill myself to be thin when
nobody knows me as a thin person. I do think it
is affecting the kind of jobs I'm getting.
And so I just kind of relaxed on my diet."
But relaxing on his diet didn't mean that
Suplee was unhealthy. On the contrary,
the actor bulked up and is at a place where
he's happy with his weight and physique.
Of course, Suplee's weight loss journey began when
he started dating his future wife, Brandy Lewis,
the younger sister of actor-singer Juliette
Lewis, in 2001. As Suplee told People in 2022 -
"I became, for the first time in my
life, kind of interested in the future
and having experiences with her. Like
spending a day walking around a museum
or going on a trip or hiking that I
just wasn't physically able to do."
Suplee went on to explain that while he had been
crazy about Lewis since the pair were teenagers,
it took her much longer to feel
the same way. Once she did however,
it was the first time in Suplee's life that he
felt accepted by someone for who he was as opposed
to what he looked like. From there, the couple
married in 2006 and they have four daughters.
"I was possibly going to
have the life that I wanted,
but it required a little extra effort on my part."
The support of Ethan Suplee's family wasn't
the only thing that changed his perspective
on physical health. In the very first
episode of his "American Glutton" podcast,
Suplee recounts a strange encounter he had with
"Passion of the Christ" star Jim Caviezel while
on his way to film "Cold Mountain." On the
plane, Caviezel sat beside the actor and
confronted him on his way of life, specifically
noting, according to Suplee, that if your life
doesn't emulate Jesus Christ, you're going to
hell. Suplee recalled the conversation, saying -
"It was the first conversation of that
nature that I'd ever had with somebody.
Nobody had ever talked to me like that.
Nobody had ever said: 'Look at yourself,
you're going to f—ing hell... You don't
care about yourself at all, you're a mess.'"
Suplee stated that Caviezel was never unkind to
him during this encounter, but nevertheless, the
conversation understandably shook him. The actor
recalled his feelings after the talk, saying -
"I'm not saying he was right or that my
decision had anything to do with Jesus Christ,
but my decision was, 'I don't want people
to feel they can talk to me like that.'"
A breath of fresh air nowadays,
Ethan Suplee is hard to offend,
even after his incredible weight loss journey.
"You're in these movies and you were very,
you know, overweight, does that - obese?"
"I was-you, whatever - You can't
offend me with those words."
For a long time, the actor was known
because of his overweight stature,
a look that helped him land roles in "Remember
the Titans" and "My Name is Earl," but that
part of his life is behind him now, going
on to say on the "Timcast IRL" podcast -
"I've definitely had some people say
that, 'I preferred you fat,' and I just
don't care. […] I had been wanting to be
the size I am now for so long that like,
how you want me to be doesn't really matter."
Using his influence on social
media, through his podcast,
and his physical on-screen transformation,
Suplee hopes to inspire others to step up
and make the change themselves. According
to Suplee, this doesn't necessarily require
expunging foods from your diet but rather
a balance. He said on "Timcast IRL" -
"Taking an entire food group and demonizing it,
and cutting it out of my
life, that's also extreme."